كانت الغارة الدراماتيكية في فندق مينتس في
جميع أنحاء التلفزيون الحكومي
[موسيقى] من
قبل القوات الخاصة الروسية التي عرضت
القبض على هذه المجموعة من المرتزقة الروس المزعومين ،
وبعض المقاتلين ذوي الخبرة.
تم التأكد من أن هؤلاء الروس
لديهم خبرة قتالية حقيقية
وشاركوا بالفعل في نزاعات مسلحة حذر قائد
الشرطة الروسية بيلا المقنع بشدة
في ذلك الوقت
ولكن ما لم يكن يعرفه هو سبب وجود هذه
المجموعة الغامضة من الروس
فعلاً القليل منهم حتى الآن على
ما يرام  حسنًا ، نحن الآن في طريقنا إلى
مكان غير معلوم في ضواحي
كييف العاصمة الأوكرانية ،
وكان من المقرر أن نلتقي بمجموعة من مسؤولي
المخابرات العسكرية والأوكرانية السابقين
الذين لديهم قصة غير عادية
حول ما حدث بالفعل في
بيلاروسيا وكيف كان هؤلاء
المرتزقة الروس  كانت في الواقع جزءًا من
عملية لدغة متقنة بقيادة أوكرانيا
للقبض على جريمة الحرب الروسية المشتبه بها
من
أجل تقديمهم إلى العدالة هنا
، تحدث الضباط الكبار السابقون
إلى CNN بشرط أن نحمي
هوياتهم ، وليسوا مخولين
بالكشف عن تفاصيل ما يقولون إنها
خطة طموحة شديدة السرية تدعمها
الولايات المتحدة وفشلت في النهاية
لحظة عندما تدخل بيلاروسيا عندما رأيت
كل هؤلاء
المرتزقة الروس يتم القبض عليهم في بيلاروسيا ،
كان ذلك بمثابة كابوس بالنسبة لك ،
ما الذي كنت تعتقد أن الشعور الذي أصابني كان سيئًا للغاية
لأنه يعني أن كل عملنا الشاق
قد ذهب في البالوعة.
استعد لأكثر من عام على
أمل أن تسود العدالة
وأن يكون هؤلاء اللصوص في السجن ومعاقبتهم
للأسف ، لم يحدث هذا
عندما يقول اللصوص إنه يعني
المقاتلين المدعومين من روسيا الذين يقاتلون
القوات الحكومية الأوكرانية في
شرق البلاد الانفصالي
بينهم.  هم مواطنون روس
متهمون بالتورط في بعض من أسوأ
الفظائع في الحرب
مثل إسقاط
طائرة ركاب ماليزية MH17 في عام 2014 مع نيا
تقول مصادر استخباراتنا 300 شخصًا إن الرجال
المحتجزين في بيلاروسيا تم التعرف عليهم
على مدى عدة أشهر على أنهم يشتبه في
صلتهم بجرائم حرب ،
وكان هناك شخصان
موجودان عندما تم إطلاق الصاروخ الذي أسقط mh17 ، وكان
أربعة آخرون أعضاء في مجموعة
مسؤولة عن  أسقطنا
طائرتنا العسكرية وقتل ما لا يقل عن
70 من أفضل رجالنا ، لذا فإن تحديد
هؤلاء الأشخاص ومعاقبتهم كان ذا أهمية كبيرة
بالنسبة لنا ،
ومن الواضح أنه كان من مصلحة
المخابرات لنا أيضًا على الرغم من أن المسؤولين الأمريكيين
ينفون أن يكون لهم أي دور مباشر
وفقًا
لمصادرنا -  حصلت عملية بقيادة الولايات المتحدة على بعض
المساعدة الفنية النقدية والمشورة
من وكالة المخابرات المركزية بشأن رسم
المرتزقة الروس في
مسؤول أمريكي كبير قال لشبكة CNN أن هذه
المزاعم خاطئة
ولكن تحديد الأشخاص المناسبين ومن
ثم استدراجهم خارج روسيا
يتطلب خداعًا مفصلاً ، لذا فإن
مصادر المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية السابقة
أخبرونا أنهم شرعوا في إنشاء
شركة عسكرية خاصة وهمية مع  يمتلكون
موقعًا باللغة الروسية على الإنترنت ،
أعلنوا عن وظائف مثل عقد واحد مربح
بقيمة خمسة آلاف دولار شهريًا
لحماية منشآت النفط في فنزويلا
وكان هذا هو الطُعم وقد أخبرنا
المئات من المرتزقة الروس أن
كل ما كان عليهم فعله وفقًا
لمصادرنا هو  أثبتوا من
هم وأين قاتلوا ، بدأنا في الاتصال
بهم ونقول يا رجل حسنًا ، أخبرني
شيئًا عن نفسك
ربما لست مقاتلًا حقًا ، ربما
أنت سباك أو شيء من هذا القبيل
، ثم بدأوا في الكشف عن أشياء
عن أنفسهم
أرسلوا إلينا وثائق هويات عسكرية
وإثباتًا للمكان الذي قاتلوا فيه
، ونحن مثل لعبة البنغو التي يمكننا استخدامها
لأنهم يرسلون إليك دليلًا على من
هم ، نعم ، أرسلوا إلينا
في الواقع تمامًا ما تبع ذلك وفقًا
لمصادرنا  المتطوعين بحرية
ليس فقط الوثائق والصور ولكن من
المحتمل أن تدين مقاطع الفيديو مثل
هذا الفيديو بعد إسقاط
طائرة عسكرية أوكرانية في منطقة
الحرب الشرقية
قدمها المقاتلون أنفسهم ،
كل ما كان على المخابرات الأوكرانية فعله هو
اختيار الأشخاص الذين أرادوا تقديم
عقود فنزويلا المربحة
وبسبب قيود السفر kovid 19
في روسيا ، قم
بتجميعهم في بيلاروسيا المجاورة لتخرج
مصادر استخباراتنا وتقول إن الخطة الحقيقية
كانت  قم بإنزالهم في أوكرانيا
وقم بالاعتقالات
إذا كان هؤلاء الأشخاص قد انتهى بهم الأمر هنا
في
أوكرانيا ، لكانت تفاصيل أعمالهم الإجرامية
معروفة في جميع أنحاء العالم ، وكان
بإمكان أوكرانيا تقديمهم إلى
العدالة
وإظهار أن معركتنا مع روسيا
خطيرة وأننا  لن نرفع
أيدينا ونستسلم
لكن الخطة فشلت عندما
ألقى البيلاروسيون القبض على المجموعة
قبل ساعات فقط من المفترض أن يقودوا ، كان من
الممكن أن يكون ضربة قوية
لموسكو
بدلاً من ذلك ، وفقًا لمصادرنا ،
تم إحباط عملية استخبارات أوكرانية جريئة